- No one is perfect at everything.
And we're all made to
be perfectly imperfect.
I was rejected but it was the
best rejection ever for me
to lead me in a different direction,
the direction where I'm
heading towards right now.
You learn way more when you
fail than when you succeed.
That's something I can guarantee you on.
You want to tell stories and
you want something that can last
longer than just a one hit wonder.
- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that you have the ability
to do something special
that can change the planet.
So, to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from
YouTuber and entrepreneur
Michelle Phan, and my take on
her top ten rules for success.
Rule number six is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
(uplifting tune)
- I came from a mother and
father who are both immigrants,
didn't speak English,
so I had to learn English on my own,
I had to learn it through
TV and through school
and I had to learn how to
speak Vietnamese at home.
Everything that I know of today
I had to teach myself,
I had to learn from other people,
bring on mentors,
and also adapting.
Silencing my mind,
and just observing quietly
and adapting to that.
Even when I was doing YouTube,
everyone thought I was crazy,
everyone thought I was stupid,
like, they literally
said, oh, that's so dumb,
you could never make money on YouTube,
why would you do that?
Why not just go get a corporate job?
I followed the beat of my own heart
and that beat led me here.
Find your qualities.
Instead of focusing on the negative,
which I know can be hard,
focus on the positive.
And it doesn't have to
be a physical thing.
Maybe you're amazing at Mario Kart
or you're a brilliant pianist,
an amazing painter, a singer,
you make great grades at school.
No one is perfect at everything
and we're all made to
be perfectly imperfect.
Kind of like this crystal.
See, it's not perfectly cut
like a flawless diamond,
but it's beautiful in its own unique way.
There won't be another
crystal like this one
and just like you,
it has many, many facets
and you'll be discovering
more of them as time goes by
and if you don't think you have a quality,
just ask yourself this simple question:
what am I good at?
Everyone is good at something
and if you don't know what it is,
well, take this opportunity to find it.
Sign up for cooking
classes, painting classes,
learn how to sing, play some sports,
pick up on a passion and nurture it
because this helps build self-worth,
it gives you something
to do and strive for.
I was rejected but it was the
best rejection ever for me
to lead me in a different direction,
the direction where I'm
heading towards right now
and that was back in 2007,
I applied for a job at a
counter at department store
because I really wanted to
work in the beauty industry,
I wanted to be a makeup artist
and I wanted to empower women
through just the art of beauty.
And so, I went in,
they were looking for a sales associate
and I applied for the job,
I filled out the application,
I did the sit-down interview,
I answered all the right questions,
I mean, they were very
impressed with my knowledge
and my passion
and the last question she asked me was,
"Have you ever worked in sales?"
And I said no, you know,
I'm a waitress, you know,
I know how to host,
how to make people feel good,
and I know how to really understand
and read the fine lines
and details of people
'cause, you know, like,
when you're waiting tables,
you really have to see,
like, what someone wants
without them needing
to say anything to you.
So, it wasn't good enough for her though
because she said, "Well,
"unfortunately we do need someone that
"has experience in sales."
And I said, but I can learn, you know,
like, please give me a shot,
you know, like, just give me a
chance, I'm willing to learn,
and I know I can sell beauty.
I mean, I love it, I'm
passionate about it.
Two weeks later I never got the call back
and I was really devastated because,
you know, it's a rejection,
it's tough because I think
we're all programmed to
wanting to have, like,
positive reinforcement, you know,
we want positive reinforcement,
we want people to say
yes, we always want yes,
I mean, no is such a negative,
like, I feel like sometimes
we think no is something bad
but sometimes we need no's in our lives
to kind of shift us in
a different direction,
you know?
I always find that in
life, like, the universe,
there's always three answers
when you want something,
it's either yes,
not yet, or I have something better.
So, in this case--
- (all simultaneously) Oh!
- In this case,
I knew that there was going
to be something better,
I didn't take that rejection,
I didn't just, I didn't
drop my love for beauty,
in fact, I opened another door for myself
and that was through YouTube, my webcam.
And I said you know what?
I may not be able to have
a job as a sales associate
at a department store selling makeup,
but at least I can still
fulfill my passion in beauty
by filming these tutorials
and helping girls
and inspiring girls to
try new beauty looks
and that's what I did.
And two years later, Long Comb calls me
and they wanted me to become
their official online spokesperson.
I realized, you know,
had I have gone back in
time and told myself, hey,
you know what, this
rejection is something that
you need to take and, you
know, it's not a bad thing.
I think, like,
you know, that was the best
thing that ever happened to me
was that rejection.
So, I absolutely agree with you, Andrea,
like, sometimes rejection
is a blessing in disguise.
What do you do when you start
a business but it fails?
Well, hopefully you can
learn from all the mistakes,
all the good things,
and all the bad things
and reapply it to your new business
or reapply it to your new job
or your new career destination.
Look at Apple.
Apple is one of the most prestigious,
bankable companies in the world
and they had a lot of failures,
they had a lot of
launches that didn't work,
they had a lot of things that
just didn't click with the
audience and their customers
but that didn't stop them from
having the thriving business.
You learn way more when you
fail than when you succeed.
That's something I can guarantee you on.
I didn't prepare myself
to become a beauty guru.
It didn't just happen,
it was something that
I knew fit for myself.
I started filming on YouTube
on my webcam in college
in my room, like, just
doing makeup tutorials
and now, now, like, I work with L'Oreal
and I have, like, three companies that
I'm a CEO of,
so it's incredible how
that all happened because
I had a passion and it
all started from a webcam.
And it doesn't matter how
small your beginnings are,
it doesn't matter,
it just, all that matters
is how big your passion is.
If I had to choose one thing
that really motivates me
that I can recommend to a
lot of young entrepreneurs,
it's having that,
finding and understanding why
you're doing what you're doing,
you know, having a sense of purpose,
because oftentimes I meet so
many aspiring entrepreneurs
and they have these great ideas
but they don't even know
why they're doing it.
Money should be a byproduct
of what you love to do.
I just want to really
inspire the youth because
I've always believed in
teaching and sharing.
Not coming from an
authoritative point of view,
like, you have to use this or use that,
but this is what works best for me
and it might work best for you
and if it doesn't work for you,
then just comment and let me
know what works best for you
because there might be
someone here watching this
that we can help.
My biggest thing I would
tell myself is really
to just focus on what makes you happy.
You know, like,
don't listen to what
everyone else is telling you,
like, your parents are
pushing you in this direction,
your friends are trying
to get you to do this,
ask yourself, look at
yourself in the mirror,
and ask yourself what
do I want for myself?
You know?
And that was, when I was growing up,
it was always me pleasing my parents,
pleasing my friends, trying to fit in,
but I never once asked
myself what makes me happy,
what do I want to do?
And I think my biggest
advice is really just
taking the time and really
just finding quiet time,
giving yourself moments to reflect on
where you want to see
yourself in the next 10 years.
And really, like, being really realistic,
not about I want to impress my friends,
I want to have a nice car,
and have an amazing career,
it's not about what everyone else wants,
it's about what you want.
I want to inspire girls and show them that
you don't have to do one
thing and stick with it,
like, if you love music,
you don't really need to be a musician
if you're not a good singer,
you can manage musicians
or you can work doing, like, sound effects
or stuff like that.
There's so many different
things you can do
that you really love.
And for me, mine was beauty.
I love art but I also love beauty
and I found a way to
combine the two together
and create makeup tutorials
and show girls how to
become their own artists
and become their own makeup artists
and, in a sense,
teaching other girls to wake up every day
and apply a red lipstick
to feel confident again.
What I recommend usually
when anyone is starting on YouTube
is to really focus on storytelling
because storytelling
has a longer shelf life
than just doing a funny viral video,
like, you want to tell stories
and you want something
that can last longer
than just a one hit wonder.
It's like any business you build, I mean,
before you start you have to know
exactly what are you selling,
what are you projecting,
what's your message,
what's your vision, what's
your brand identity?
And from there, you can work.
I wanted to make this video
to remind you guys that
it's okay to feel stressed,
it's very natural,
but the thing is you can't
feel stressed all the time.
Even something like this,
a phone, a machine messes up
and remember, guys,
we also have to charge these things,
they don't just run on forever,
even they need a break.
And so, if something like
a cell phone, a machine,
needs a break, imagine us.
We need to give ourselves time to relax,
to recharge,
to find and seek that inner peace.
This day and age where
everything is moving so fast
and we're always wanting
to be in the know,
we're trying to keep up with everything.
There's this pressure to always be on
but there's nothing wrong with
just turning everything off.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
MJ Illustrates asked me to.
If there's someone you'd like
to vote on for the next top 10
check out the link in the description
and go and have your say.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Marian Lizzi
who was my publisher from
Penguin Random House.
Marian, thank you so much for your support
on this one word book journey
and I really appreciate the
picture you took on Instagram
and shared it with your following as well.
Thank you again.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, see you soon.
- I know not everyone in
the world has the luxury
to do their dream job because
they have to make money,
they have to hustle,
they have to accept a job
that they might not want to do
or they hate.
Every idea has a million
different roadmaps.
If you love origami,
have you perhaps thought
about going into engineering,
learning coding, developing an app,
designing, even.
There's so many different
paths that you can take
and there's no one size fit for
all rule for your dream job.
There's so many different
things you can do
with your giftings.
If you do have a dream job idea,
have that as a goal
but leave room for yourself to grow
and explore different options.
It's easy, just engage.
Engage with your viewers.
Actually go out and talk to them
and show them that you are talking to them
and you are interested in what they think.
You just really have to
have a two way conversation
with the people who are
watching your stuff because
traditional media, it was
just a one way street.
With new media, when you're
watching the content,
you start seeing all these
comments from other viewers
and that in itself
creates a new content too.
Sometimes they're debating,
sometimes they're adding value,
sometimes it's just really funny comments
but I think now it's really
just having a social aspect
to the content that you're creating.
Consciously, think positive thoughts,
especially during moments
when you're feeling down.
So, take a deep breath,
and remind yourself that life is too short
and you got to make the best of it.
Listen to music that will lift your mood.
A good beat and sound has been proven
to help people in a positive way.
Music and sound has been known
to help the growth of plants.
That says a lot.
You want to have a healthy habit
of maintaining this mental muscle
but you also don't want to overdo it.
Everything in moderation,
balance is key.
It's good to remind
yourself from time to time
how worthy and how, you
know, awesome you are
but you also want to leave
room to grow and improve.
I mean, we can all change
and evolve for the better.